i love you mommy i love you albert
four-year-old albert butler wears a
backpack filled with a specialty formula
that slowly feeds him 22 hours a day his
mother jess butler says this is what her
son with special needs must have to grow
it was super critical when he was an
infant and this is like the only thing
that he could tolerate and
was kind of the first time we saw any
growth out of him at all was on this
formula but store shelves in the united
states are running out of infant and
toddler formula
the tracking firm dad assembly reports
there's 43 percent less of it nationwide
pandemic supply chain problems started
the trouble and a factory closure in
michigan made it worse
abbott nutrition maker of the popular
similac brand halted production after
several babies got sick and two died
after drinking possibly contaminated
formula
the government investigated and found no
further danger but the company says it
will be weeks before production resumes
butler has taken extraordinary measures
to find formula for her son even flying
across the country to buy it from a
woman she met online only to be scammed
she never showed and eventually just
blew me off
parents say walking out of a store with
baby formula can now feel like walking
out with gold hoarding has become a
concern with stores now limiting how
many they sell to each parent it's
important to remember that
for babies on formula this is the only
food option
there is no substitute
and um i think um
we have to probably re-evaluate
um
what's
critical um infrastructure
really means
critics have blamed the white house for
failing to help
president biden met with retailers and
baby formula manufacturers on thursday
hoping to help ease the shortage i think
we're going to be in a matter of weeks
or less getting significantly more
formula on shelves
and the fda is also sure we can import
and still maintain the sa the high
safety standards
for now parents are making do by turning
to food banks or just feeding their
children less
let's all work together because these
are babies
you know they gotta eat
for parents there's no more urgent need
than this
nutrition for their hungry children
heidi jo castro al jazeera washington